Mike Tirico speaking of health the NBC
football night in America host Notre
Dame play-by-play host the Olympic he
does everything for the network Big Shot
Mike Tirico joining us on the program
Mike thanks for taking time out of your
busy day to join this little program
which which Dan that has the largest
hand size
McLovin as that has that measurement
happened yet on the show it has yeah
okay yes but that doesn't mean he can
play high C III understand I just being
in Indianapolis justjust for a day but I
think that's these are all the very
important questions as everybody walks
around the what do you run what did he
measure it it is kind of a bizarre a
bizarre way to evaluate who your future
employees are going to be it can do it
collectively with 31 other folks at the
same time this whole combine thing is a
is unique and it it look it keeps the
NFL in season for every season I mean
here we are a month removed from the end
of it not even a month removed we're 5.5
months away from seeing games again and
we're talking about all these guys a
projective it it's a it's a PR one for
sure well we had Daniel Jeremiah on last
hour and he's a scout or former scout
and I said Daniel we're so concerned
about the quarterbacks shouldn't we find
out what the wide receivers hand size is
because they have to catch they have to
catch the ball and no I don't know what
Jerry Rice's hand size was but I'm gonna
guess it was pretty good because he
seemed to catch everything thrown his
way ya can catch her body capture all
those all those things come up III think
I think what's happened here is everyone
tries to find the new edge because
everyone is going after the same stuff
yeah really what's happening almost as
much as the assessment of the future
talent in terms of the measurements the
interviews all the basic combine stuff
which has value as I said it's all
tongue-in-cheek I think this has really
become is the coaches the GM's having
these conversations with the agents to
prepare for free agency is going to look
like because you can't look at free
agency and the draft as separate you
have to look at them together to figure
out with your salary cap and your team
back home
how it's all going to fit what you guys
you're going to resize this talk to it
GM was talking about we have to get an
assessment of how many of our guys can
we keep our coaching staff would love to
keep a certain number but we can't so
you've got to balance that and then when
you know K we may lose this linebacker
this safety we're in the draft can we
find somebody who can be a person we
could plug in in place there so it's a
huge mosaic that this is the time of the
year for the GM's
to really earn their money to try to
figure out all this stuff and end up
with fifteen three guys you're going to
camp were thinking you couldn't get to
the Super Bowl
speaking of mosaic this 17 games
scheduled at 17th game how do you think
the networks are going or you know the
schedule makers are going to approach
this of where where does that 17th game
live on the road at home neutral site
well you know I've heard a lot of the
folks talk in neutral site for all of
them but it foreveryone 17th game to me
and I had not heard this specifically to
me it seems like it would just alternate
where one year you have nine home games
when you have eight road games because
if you go to three pre seasons and 17
regular season stand then you get to
twenty games right twenty becomes 10 at
home 10 on the road so in the years that
you can play nine home games get one
home preseason the years they play eight
road games get to eight or eight home
games excuse me you get two preseason
games at home why in either scenario you
get 10 games to sell for your season
tickets so the number of season tickets
you're selling on a year-to-year basis
becomes the same and then you siphon off
on a rotating basis one game for playing
in London or one game for playing in
Mexico City I don't think we're going to
see 16 international games to take up
that 17th game for each team you know
which which would do the math and then
get you to that final number so I think
it'll be nine home home games for your
team 8 Road and then it puts the next
year yeah I was wondering about that
that I would love to have neutral sites
where you went to college towns and gave
them an opportunity to experience the
NFL yeah I don't like if you went to
Lincoln Nebraska or you went to Auburn
Alabama whatever it is right just just
to have that spectacle and you got a
whole different environment I think that
would be fun I don't
want to export our sport here I know
Mexico City and they want to grow the
game and maybe Germany in London but I'd
like to keep as much in the United
States as possible but but what about
what let's say let's say we do that and
you know you move a Bengals game to the
shoe or you move a Lions game to the big
house in Ann Arbor against the Packers
so but it all sounds really cool is
there the infrastructure there from
x-ray facilities replay machines all the
infrastructure the NFL every field is
gonna have to be remarked right because
the hash marks are different Mike don't
be a buzzkill you're being a buzzkill
I'm sorry I'm sorry okay that's a great
idea what's doing all right thank you
Mike talking to Mike Tirico from NBC
Sports all right what is the deadline
date whether or not we decide to have
these Olympics in Tokyo what have you
been told but we haven't been told
anything specifically just a dick pound
who's from the IOC he's the longest
tenured member of the International
Olympic Committee even even longer than
Thomas Bach who's the head of the IOC
right now his interview with The
Associated Press yesterday you know got
a lot of attention because he pointed to
a date somewhere in mid to late May
almost like the date where the ball
would have to start rolling downhill to
be prepared to open the games in that
third full week of July in in Tokyo just
the infrastructure of getting all the
building and everything going in place
Tokyo is by and large in place to host
the games now with all the structures
and things like that so the headline was
hey if it may be a three month window to
know if the games are going to be on or
not what he also did say within that was
right now it seems like things will
happen on time I just don't think
anybody knows where this coronavirus is
gonna go I mean they we heard Monday in
the u.s. from the CDC they're concerned
about hey we should be planning for
being out of school for a while
telecommuting all that stuff so I don't
think we have any idea at home so
obviously what's happening in every
country is going to have a huge impact
on if the Olympics are here so they say
that there's an answer now would be
crazy but I think dick pound who knows
this thing and was made
not speaking for the whole IOC what was
speaking as a member has been around for
a long time maybe a good sense of a
window where you'd have to put up a red
flag if you could go through with it how
much research have you done on the
corona virus on the corona virus not as
much as I've done on the on the athlete
that we hope to see in Tokyo so but
certainly as you as you hear about it
you understand that they don't know
everything just yet they don't know how
it's being communicated person to person
place to place why these locations where
it shows up it's showing up and
spreading quickly so I think we have so
many questions I got on a plane
yesterday and I'm already one of those
people who like sound the the hand rest
of the tray table and all that stuff to
be human but I noticed many many more
people doing that than normal
on the plane so I think it's starting to
get on our conscience as Americans now
of we have no idea who's been on this
plane where it's been and where it's
going so I think it's going to impact
all of us and how we operate until we
know more answers about it
I wanted to have you on for a variety of
reasons obviously the Olympics and all
those years that you've covered the NBA
I was just curious did you have a
favorite Kobe Bryant storing dozens III
guess the one that comes out was the
night before his last game when you know
he had not been playing much towards the
end in terms of minutes but ramped it up
towards the end and we didn't we didn't
think he had a ton of minutes in him and
he ends up taking 50 shots and scoring
60 points but also I think you and Hubie
were talking about we've been told that
he's gonna play a certain number of
minutes or right I remember that and
then you know he just stayed in there
like you were going we don't know how
long he's gonna play certain number of
minutes or points and next thing you
know he's standing out there and that
came from the pre-gaming so as you know
Dan sometimes we all were working NBA
and finals and different things like
that sometimes you get a player who will
come in more after a morning shoot
around the rarely week but you might get
a player you know in that hour and a
half before tip the locker rooms always
open close always hard to find the star
guy in the locker right
but for Kobe's last game we got Kobe for
several minutes pregame
just me QB Brown Lisa Salters was our
sideline reporter at Fiber shop was our
producer for that game and Kobe gave us
like 15-20 minutes it was just really
good it was the ultimate respect that so
many people are on the league had for
Hubie Brown and it was like just a great
great conversation and we left there
nobody was going to give it as much as
he had but never thinking for a second
that he at 50 shots or 60 points
not even close and it's when they reared
the game the night after Kobe passed I
was standing there I was in a hotel in
Connecticut I was just standing there
watching the game and I realized about
25 minutes later that I was frozen
standing watching the game I did the
game was like I was watching how we call
the game it just took me back to how
incredible that evening was for a
terrible Lakers team it looked like it
was an atmosphere for the finals and you
just kind of pinch yourself because you
never thought you'd be watching it
through that prism just a short time
later and I that show that Monday after
Kobe died I said you know it's gonna
sound strange to this audience but the
one word that always stood out with Kobe
was he was curious he's the most curious
athlete I've ever been around there no
matter what you were talking about like
he wanted to learn if he didn't know
that he wanted to learn and if he did
learn he wanted to learn to be better
and I that would always impressed me but
I think his approach was whether it was
being a father being a husband being an
entrepreneur being a basketball player
the curiosity is what he was trying to
figure out how do would I be great at
everything whether it was basketball or
not and I just I found that fascinating
I have not come across somebody that
curious in you know 35 years people
always asked in hey when you go talk to
players you do these production meetings
we often talk about in network TV sports
who are the guys who enjoy talking to
the most and I say look I hate to be
boring but Tom Brady Peyton Manning and
Drew Brees and Kobe Bryant and players
like that they were the best players
because there's an intellectual as you
said so well like an intellectual
fascination and cure to go with their
athletic brilliance like that the the
triangulation of those two
clothes opportunity yield the greatest
players in sports it doesn't just happen
they have thought about every aspect of
you when you talk to LeBron
there was a postgame interview on ESPN I
think it was this week after LeBron hit
the shot maybe the Laker game yeah make
yourself a game on Sunday
you know LeBron give you that detail
about you're like oh he didn't just back
him down and take a shot no they've
thought about this they will live it
every second and when they share that
with you in those settings you kind of
understand why the greater the grip if I
said you could and you can have Luca
Danzig stock or Zion Williamson stock
moving on look up because I think he
makes the guys around you better but
after seeing Zion in this small sample
we see more of d'entre CH that did ion
man you're he's gonna give you so much
attention that you're gonna get a lot of
open shots you're getting a lot of
transition stuff I didn't think given
how long he was out that he jump in and
have this kind of impact I remember
watching that first game and watch Dave
Pasch call that game like okay this was
all hype this is an extent he scored all
those points in a row in the fourth
quarters before you had to come out with
this time let go all right let's see him
do it again and now we've seen it on a
pretty regular basis like wow and it's
good each TV guy that's what the leaks
but listen this year you know you wanted
to go watch Steph no hit nine threes or
play and it's been there this year and
not in as much volume and now you've got
another person who gives you that and I
think that will give a bounce back to
the leaks race as we go through the rest
of the season good to talk to you bud
hope to talk to you before you head to
the Olympics but thanks for joining us
as always any time Mike Tirico NBC
sports for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]